hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one very important idea in the social
contract or contract harrion theory of
justice and by extension of ethics that
Rawls is is articulating in his work a
theory of justice is what he terms
reflective equilibrium and this is a
technical term that he's using to
describe a process you might say if we
want to be very metaphorical by which we
fine-tune our moral judgments and
thereby hopefully also our ethical or
moral comportment behaviors motivations
and also how we change things within
society in a way that allows us a
certain flexibility and open-endedness
to moral development
so he brings it up first in chapter 4
very early on in the work saying that
there's a state of affairs I refer to as
reflective equilibrium and what is this
so if we back up a little bit he says we
we look at the initial situation which
is
you know making decisions about what
kind of society we would we would work
out for ourselves and for others in a
state of ignorance of where our location
in that society would be or what our
what our particular psychological
proclivities any of those sorts of
things and that then leads to four
rational beings according to Rawls
several principles of justice two main
ones that are pretty broad in their
their extent and there you know
prescriptive they tell us that we should
have as much Liberty as possible
compatible with the liberty of others we
should be equal in that respect but we
should also have inequalities when they
work out to the advantage of all not
just the advantage of the largest number
or aggregate as an utilitarianism but
they work out for everybody including
the the people who are the most
disadvantaged in society so that's you
know very good on a sort of high level
of abstraction but that doesn't tell us
exactly what we ought to do in
decision-making in our ordinary day to
day cases and he says that you know when
it comes to deciding precisely how
Authority and income or goods like that
ought to be justly distributed it's kind
of tough to decide you know in an
abstract a priori manner we have to work
this out through the application of the
theory so he says in searching for the
most favored description of this
situation the initial situation we work
from both ends we begin by describing it
so it represents generally shared we
things we can all agree on and
preferably weak conditions we then see
if these conditions are strong enough to
yield a significant set of principles if
not we look for further premises we have
to add something to the mix equally
reasonable but Rawls thinks that he's
already got that but if so and these
principles match are considered
convictions of justice then so far well
and good then here's where the fly gets
into the
presumably there will be discrepancies
discrepancies of what sort well people
can't entirely agree or we enact some
policy and then we see that there's some
unintended consequences so we are trying
to make things more equal and we've
created new forms of inequality there's
all sorts of things that can come up so
he says then what do we do we have a
choice we can modify the account to the
initial situation or we can revise our
existing judgments and judgments here we
should take to be sort of our you know
core ideas about what's right and wrong
what's just and unjust what's what's you
know ought to be done in this situation
he says we can revise our judgments for
even the judgments we take provisionally
as fixed points are liable to revision
and that's part of moral life if you
consult your own experience Rawls
doesn't refer to that here but you might
want to think about that have you ever
changed your mind about something that
you held is very strongly you know you
have strong conviction you think that
you're being very objective and then
later on you're like well is actually
wrong about that I need to change my
judgment the answer is probably yes
unless you were somehow incredibly lucky
to have wound up with the perfect set of
moral principles from the beginning or
you should have done it and you haven't
done it so going on he says going back
and forth sometimes altering the
conditions of contractual circumstances
and others withdrawing our judgments and
conforming them to principle I assume we
will find a description of the initial
situation that both expresses reasonable
conditions and yields principles which
match our considered judgments duly
pruned and adjusted this is what he
calls reflective equilibrium so
reflective equilibrium is a state and
end position that you're getting to it's
also you know he talks about the process
of reflective equilibrium and what he
means by that is how you're actually
getting there there's this
back-and-forth process until the
judgments and the principles CO and
side and he also says to this is quite
important that's why it's an equilibrium
we have a coincidence there and it's
reflective because we know to what
principles our judgments conform and the
premises of their derivation we actually
know what we're doing it's not just gut
feelings or responding to things on the
spur of the moment we've actually
thought things out we've talked things
out
we've worked them through you might say
then he says at this moment everything
is order but this equilibrium is not
necessarily stable says it's liable to
be upset by further examinations of the
conditions which should be imposed on
the contractual situation and by
particular cases which may lead us to
revise our judgment how might that take
place well you know we might have
entered into the situation and made some
some big assumptions about what equality
of you know these these different
liberties would actually look like and
maybe we didn't think it through
sufficiently when it comes to people who
are in disadvantaged situations that we
don't really know that well because
we're not experiencing that kind of
disadvantage ourselves or we don't spend
enough time with those who are and find
out about it you know a great example of
this would be thinking about workplace
issues and the the entrance on mass of
women into certain types of workplaces
where there were what we call glass
ceilings and a lot of institutional bias
and you know it took a little while for
us to realize that if you actually want
to have workplace fairness you probably
need to have some flexibility in
scheduling because why because as it
turns out empirically now it's changing
a little bit but it's still you know
tilted a little bit so it's a one end
for even for the younger generations
here in America women spend more of the
time doing caretaking both of children
and of other people than do men so we'd
have to include that into our figuring
out okay
what actually looks fair within the
initial situation and what fits the
principles of justice and then we can
hit a new reflective equilibrium so what
we end up doing is moving to one
reflective equilibrium and then we say
oh this is this is good but it turns out
it's not completely stable there's more
and more discrepancy and then we come to
another one so this is a continual
progressive process for somebody like
Rawls which can lead to a lot of
frustration on the part of people who
want there to be a once and for all a
Creed upon stable equilibrium that
nobody will ever question again wait a
second we gave you these rights can't
you be content with those well no
because we actually still need to keep
working out what's just unfair by
looking at how the principles and our
judgments actually do work out in the
the situations so he says I'm not going
to work through this entire process but
we might want to think about this a
little bit later on in Chapter nine some
remarks about moral theory after
discussing you know what moral theory is
is about he brings up again reflective
equilibrium and he says the the need for
this idea arises as follows according to
the provisional aim of moral philosophy
what's the provisional aim of moral
philosophy he's called it the attempt to
describe our moral capacities our moral
capacities are our abilities to make
good judgments he says according to the
provisional aim of moral philosophy one
might say that justice is fairness is
the hypothesis that the principles which
would be chosen in the original position
are identical with those that match our
here's another technical term consider
two judgments and so these principles
describe our sense of justice now what
is a considered judgment he specified
that in the paragraph just earlier he
says they are those rendered under
conditions favourable to the exercise of
the sense of justice
therefore in circumstances where the
more common excuses
explanations for making a mistake do not
apply the person has the ability
opportunity and desire to reach a
correct decision or at least not the
desire not to what would be examples of
things that would interfere with
considered decisions he gives you
several of these he says we can discard
judgments made with hesitation or those
in which we have little confidence those
which we gave and were upset or
frightened or those when we stand to
gain one way or the other so we need to
be impartial not moved by our emotions I
think we could also add to this two
judgments that are not being made under
the duress of having to make a decision
right now at this point in time that
that's a common trick to make people
make moral decisions under the stress of
a very compressed time so our our
considered judgments he says they are
not perfect and so we need to work out a
reflective equilibrium he says we must
make an allowance for the likelihood
that considered judgments even when
we're not biased we've got enough time
we've got access to information we can
still have certain irregularities and
distortions he says despite the fact
that they're rendered under favorable
circumstances so he says when a person
is presented with an intuitively
appealing account of his sense of
justice he may well revise his judgments
to conform to its principles even though
the fit theory does not fit his existing
judgments exactly he's especially likely
to do this if you can find an
explanation for the deviations and if
the conception presented yields a
judgment which he finds he can now
accept so this is a process of as I
mentioned at the beginning sort of
fine-tuning our moral judgments about
what's right and wrong about what people
deserve about what equality looks like
about what inequality looks like what
justifies adequately inequality by
benefiting those who are worse off so we
we do need to re-examine
are considered judgments from time to
time and that means that we're getting a
more and more robust conception of what
the initial situation and what the
principles of justice look like in the
concrete this is absolutely necessary
for a good practical decision-making and
moral evaluation in real-life situations
if we wanted to put Rawls to use there's
one other thing that he says about
reflective equilibrium in this chapter
that I think it's very helpful to keep
in mind for the average reader and and
here we can see that for Rawls there is
a difference between what we do in
ordinary day-to-day decision-making on
an ethical basis or say political
decision-making and what we would do
when we're doing political theory or
engaging in ethics as a branch of
philosophy so he says that there's
really two interpretations of reflective
equilibrium he says it depends on
whether we are to be presented with only
those descriptions descriptions of the
initial situation and principles of
justice which more or less match our
existing judgments except for minor
discrepancies so we're looking at like
you know how do we tweak it this way how
do we tweak it this way we have a sort
of narrowed realm of choice or whether
want us to be presented with all
possible descriptions to which one might
plausibly conform one's judgments
together with all relevant philosophical
arguments for them so these are two very
different kinds of operations here right
one is much more limited more restricted
and we do it all the time the other is
we pause and we say okay we got to like
open up the discussion to all the
possible ways of looking at it and the
philosophical justifications for it that
is in fact what we do in moral
philosophy when we're doing it you know
sort of professionally you could say or
when we're doing it in a adequate way
even as as non-professionals so he goes
on and he says in the first case we're
describing a person's sense of justice
more or less as it is allowing for the
smoothing out of certain irregularities
all right but in the second he says the
equilibrium that we're aiming at the
reflective equilibrium is the one
concerned with in moral philosophy Rawls
is also rather realistic he says I don't
know if we're gonna reach this state in
moral philosophy but at least that's
what we would be doing so the two of
them can inform each other right we can
we can use moral philosophy to to push
the envelope a little bit further
ethically speaking but much of what
we're doing when we're aiming at
reflective equilibrium is not
necessarily having to do philosophy at
every single point otherwise we wouldn't
we wouldn't actually get much
accomplished so that is what reflective
equilibrium is and why it's important in
Rawls's social contract ethics and
theory of justice
you